und zugeschaltet aus münster ist die
umweltministerinnen guten tag frau
schulze guten tag frau schulz in der
regierungskommission in der auch ihr
haus vertreten ist schlägt ein
tempolimit vor damit deutschland seine
klimaziele erreiche dann setzen sie das
um
naja erstmal muss diese kommission ja
arbeiten und ich gehe fest davon aus
dass der verkehrsminister sich an die
verabredung hält im märz seien maßnahmen
programm vorzulegen und er muss genau
beschreiben wie wir denn den co2 ausstoß
im verkehrsbereich reduzieren können und
ich glaube dass es da ein ganzes paket
von maßnahmen geben muss sie haben jetzt
auf den verkehrsminister verwiesen dann
setzen sie denn ein tempolimit um oder
dann setzen sie sich dafür ein event ist
das ja mal einen beschluss der spd
gewesen auf einem parteitag für den
klimaschutz ist die gesamte
bundesregierung zuständig und jeder muss
in seinem bereich dafür sorgen dass wir
den co2 abdruck den wir als land haben
dass wir den wirklich reduzieren und der
scheuer wird das für den verkehrsbereich
machen genauso wie frau klöckner für die
landwirtschaft aber noch mal bei ihnen
gefragt als umweltministerin wie werden
sie da druck machen teilen sie die
forderung nach einem tempolimit wie
erklären sie den jugendlichen wieder
freitags für ihre zukunft demonstrieren
dass sie trotz klimawandels auf eine
reduzierung von schadstoffen
möglicherweise verzichten nur damit die
eltern weiter rasen können ich werde
jetzt in diesem jahr ein
klimaschutzgesetz vorlegen und in diesem
klimaschutzgesetz werden wir genau
beschreiben wie wir den weg hin zur
reduzierung geben bisher haben wir ja
immer nur ziele festgelegt und jetzt
werden wir festlegen wie der weg dahin
ist damit wir eben in 20-30 wirklich
sagen können wir haben das verbindliche
klimaschutzziele was wir uns in paris
gegeben haben auch wirklich erreicht ich
stelle fest ich habe jetzt dreimal
gefragt nach ihrer position und eben
noch mal nach einem parteitagsbeschluss
der spd da steht ein tempolimit drin das
position ihrer partei klar gefragt gilt
das für sie und ihre partei noch dass
sie für ein tempolimit in deutschland
auf autobahnen sind weil ich kann das
gut verstehen dass sie jetzt von mir
eine positionierung zu den vorschlägen
von herrn scheuer haben wollen aber
erstmal muss her schauer wirklich sagen
was er will er muss das vorlegen was in
seiner kompetenz liegt als
verkehrsminister nämlich zu sagen wie
wir den co2 fußabdruck hier reduzieren
und dann bin ich gerne bereit mit ihnen
darüber zu diskutieren aber es muss erst
mal einen vorschlag auf den tisch legen
und die verantwortung dazu ist ganz klar
beim verkehrsminister ja aber ich habe
nicht nach den sehr gefragt sondern auch
im spd parteitagsbeschluss gilt dennoch
naja hier geht es aber nicht um spd
parteitagsbeschlüsse hier geht es darum
wie die bundesregierung ihren beitrag
leistet dass der co2 fußabdruck in
deutschland reduziert wird und da hat
jeder einzelnen minister eine
verantwortung und der scheuer hat die
verantwortung für den verkehrsbereich
und ich bin mir ganz sicher er wird eher
ein maßnahmenprogramm vorlegen
ok in der kommission wird auch
gesprochen gibt es den vorschlag zu
höheren spritpreisen machen sie sich das
zu eigen nennt ist ihre ihr ministerium
in der kommission vertreten wann werden
sie mit höheren steuern dafür mehr
klimaschutz sorgen
auch da nochmal wir werden ein
gesamtkonzept brauchen wir haben jetzt
über die strukturwandel kommission einen
vorschlag einen kompromiss wie wir aus
der kohleverstromung aussteigen können
das ist ein ganz ganz wichtiger beitrag
das wird aber nicht reichen auch der
verkehr muss seinen co2 fußabdruck
reduzieren auch in der landwirtschaft in
der industrie wird noch eine ganze menge
passieren müssen
und wir brauchen dieses gesamtkonzept da
geht es nicht um einzelne kleine
maßnahmen damit wären wir leider nicht
weiterkommen wir brauchen ein gesamtes
klimaschutzgesetz ein gesamtplan damit
wir unsere ziele auch erreichen und ich
bin sehr zuversichtlich dass wir das
schaffen
wir sind in deutschland doch eine
industrienationen wir sind weltmeister
in innovationen und wenn das jemand
schaffen kann dann doch wieder zu zeigen
wie das geht
sie machen immer ein gesamtkonzept an
das besteht aus einzelnen maßnahmen ich
versuche ihre position dazu erfahren
ich versuche es noch mal so wer rasen
will wählt andreas scheuer während
tempolimit will wählt die grünen was
bekommen die die sie wählen von der spd
bekommen sie einen klaren plan wie wir
co2 reduzieren wir wollen nicht einzelne
maßnahmen haben sondern wir wollen dass
wir in allen bereichen beschreiben wie
wir co2 jetzt wirklich reduziert
bekommen und wir wollen das so machen
dass das menschen dass das leben für die
menschen besser wird was ist eigentlich
schlecht daran wenn in den städten die
luft sauberer wird weil die autos
weniger abgase ausschuss weil sie leise
sind weil sie immer mehr mit elektro
fahren also das ist ja heute alle die
die in den städten leben zu der klarheit
würde für mich gehören dass ich jetzt
von ihnen noch kurz erfahren ob sie für
ein tempolimit sind und darauf beharren
und erhöhungen von steuern für
treibstoffe oder nicht ich will er
einzelne vorschläge überhaupt nicht
kommentieren mir geht es darum dass wir
am ende das ziel 20 30 erreichen unseren
co2 ausstoß zu reduzieren
und da wird jeder bereich einen teil
beisteuern müssen
wir müssen runter kommen in der
mobilität und wir müssen bei den
gebäuden in der landwirtschaft in allen
bereichen innovation nach vorne bekommen
co2 reduzieren und ich bin mir sicher
dass wir das schaffen
frau schulze herzlichen dank für das
gespräch
schönen dank nach münster vielen dank